you know if I was Brad Pitt I would have
asked Angelina Jolie to come home and
the Maleficent get up and have some
private time
[Music]
Maleficent stars Angelina Jolie as the
title character and it's a reimagining
of sorts of the classic Sleeping Beauty
tale we've all heard it we've all seen
the movie we know what it's about let's
see if they can do something a little
bit different with it now a lot of
people were really excited for this
movie and I had to be honest I wasn't I
wasn't like oh my goodness I can't wait
to see Maleficent I'm so excited for
Maleficent oh my god his Oblivion I was
always like I hope that's enjoyable the
what is a movie about basically this
character Maleficent is a fairy played
by Angelina Jolie because of some really
nasty dark down dirty cold crap that
happened to her when she was younger she
lost her wings and she has a grudge
against the king of this land that's
nearby and she curses his daughter to
fall into a sleep like death when she's
16 years old however as the years go by
and as this young girl grows up she
becomes slightly attached to this girl
which makes things a little bit
difficult for her some of my friends saw
the movie and they were very
disappointed by it and they were telling
me they thought it was just kind of okay
and to them it was kind of crushing
because they were really looking forward
to this movie I wasn't done I have to
agree with my friends who saw the film
before me I thought the film was okay
but the fact of the matter is it's
different for me because I wasn't like
oh my god I can't wait to see Maleficent
so the fact that I thought the movie
wasn't total crap I left the theater
going that was all right but if you were
really excited for this movie and you
were hoping for it to be great you will
be disappointed because for the most
part it's a very visually appealing film
with a good lead performance by Angelina
Jolie some very cool set pieces and not
much else in regards to substance by far
the character you care the most about is
Maleficent which makes sense and is good
because she's the title character
however the character of Aurora or you
might know her better as Sleeping Beauty
has nothing she just is oh my gosh it's
so pretty here everything's so pretty
I'm pretty everything's pretty like
that's basically her character and the
entire emotional substance behind her
you really don't care that much about
her you care about the relationship
that's developed between her and
Maleficent because you do care about
Maleficent but everything else is just
sort of like this undercurrent
of stuff to kind of get you to the next
few scenes and it makes sense that
certain things happen in the film it's
just that you don't really care that
much about any of it and then the
addition of a young boy who sees her one
day and goes oh she's attractive also
there's really nothing there in regards
to emotional weight I know what's a
kid's film at its core and that's one of
the things that a lot of people ask me
about on Twitter some parents wanted to
know from me do you think this is
acceptable for my children I would say
you know 8 9 10 11 would probably dig
this movie a lot 12 years old but there
is some violent content in the film
there's some battles there's some scary
scenes that younger kids might be really
scared by but for the most part I think
I would love this movie if I was a kid
and I think young girls will just they
will flip out for this movie yeah and in
all honesty the movie ain't that bad
because it is a very very appealing film
to look at there are some very cold
battle sequences James Newton Howard
score is very good as well and Angelina
Jolie is great as Maleficent she has a
very dark side to her in the film a very
wickedly evil side which she would
expect with a movie like this but she
pulls it off very well and I think that
she is definitely the best part of this
movie like I said the movie looks good
it really is a visual feast for your
eyes but the substance of the film is
just there's nothing really there it
doesn't feel as if there's really any
emotional weight to the movie and the
scenes where you're kind of supposed to
care just kind of feel like really
beautiful paintings without much else
behind it also the three fairies in the
film they got on my nerves a lot and
they're in the whole movie and there's
nothing you can do about it they're just
there and you have to deal with it it's
fast paced but it ends kind of abruptly
and it doesn't feel like the film has a
good flow from first to second and third
act it really just feels like a first
act and then a second act and you're
like where's the third act I guess the
second and third kind of blended
together it just ends very abruptly the
emotional wave the character it isn't
really there but you do care about
Maleficent and Angelina Jolie is good in
the film so I'm gonna give the movie a
b-minus I think kids will dig this movie
there isn't much else going on than some
really cool looking scenes but it is
directed very nice and Jolie is good in
the film also I want to remind you guys
real quick that my promotion with Hulu
Plus comm is still going on these guys
contacted me and said we want to work
with you we want to offer your viewers
two weeks of Hulu Plus for free and Hulu
Plus is awesome I love
because they have a large majority of
the criterion collection on Hulu Plus
which is great for me because I'm a
movie lover and to see a lot of those
classic films restored is really great
also one of my favorite shows if not my
favorite show of all time the x-files is
on Hulu Plus if you guys can't see
behind me that's Mulder and Scully
examining a dead body just so you you
know I thought you'd want to know that
if you enjoy binge watching shows like I
do it's awesome because you can just
click next episode you don't have to
worry about those cliffhangers when they
happen you don't just sit there and go
like oh my gosh I'm going to die until I
know what that is because you can just
go look and then you've had the episode
right there
it's so awesome but like I said through
them there allow me to offer you guys
two weeks of Hulu Plus for free if you
go to Hulu Plus comm slash Chris
stuckman you can do that that's Hulu
Plus comm slash Chris Duckman I'm
letting you guys know about that because
it is so cold they contacted me and I
love the fact they did that that it just
cuz I'm just me you know I'm just me and
they want to work with me and give you
guys awesome stuff and I'm just sitting
here like wow that's so cool because I
love Hulu Plus and I think you guys will
too so Hulu Plus comm slash Chris
Stockman like I said they have a large
majority of the criterion collection on
there which is just that is great for
film lovers so what do you guys think of
this film what do you think of the
original Sleeping Beauty cartoon what's
your favorite Disney movie I have no
idea what - Toy Story Lion King maybe I
don't know anyway guys as always thank
you so much for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck my nose
[Music]